this is a brilliant tweet but I don't
want you to pay attention to the tweet
it's good sure but I want you to watch
the numbers that are underneath it
that's a screen recording and the
numbers are going up and down all over
the place they should just steadily rise
but they don't there aren't that many
people tapping like by mistake and then
taking it back so why can't Twitter just
count you'll see examples like this all
over the place on youtube subscriber and
view counts sometimes rise and drop
similar random or they change depending
on which device you're checking on
computers should be good at counting
right they're basically just overgrown
calculators this video that you're
watching whether it's on a tiny little
phone screen on a massive desktop
display it is all just the result of
huge amounts of math that turns a
compressed stream of binary numbers into
amounts of electricity that gets sent to
either a grid of colored pixels or a
speaker all in perfect time just
counting should be easy but sometimes it
seems to fall apart and that's usually
when there's a big complicated system
with lots of inputs and outputs when
something has to be done at scale
scaling makes things difficult to
explain why we have to talk about race
conditions caching and eventual
consistency all the code that I've
talked about in the basics so far has
been single threaded because well
because we're talking about the basics
single threaded means that it looks like
a set of instructions that the computer
steps to one after the other it starts
at the top it works its way through
ignoring everything else and at the end
it has done a thing which is fine as
long as that's the only thread the only
thing that the computers doing and that
it's the only computer doing it fine for
old machines like this but for
complicated modern systems that's never
gonna be the case most websites are at
the heart just a fancy front end to a
database YouTube is a database of videos
and comments Twitter is a database of
small messages your phone company's
billing site is a database of customers
and bank accounts but the trouble is
that a single computer holding a single
database can only deal with so much
input at once receiving a request
understanding it
the change in sending the response back
all of those take time so there are only
so many requests that can fit in each
second and if you try and handle
multiple requests at once there are
subtle problems that can show up let's
say that YouTube wants to count one view
of a video it just has the job of adding
one to the view count which seems really
simple but it's actually three separate
smaller jobs you have to read the view
count you have to add one to it and then
you have to write that view count back
into the database if two requests come
along very close to each other and
they're assigned to separate threads it
is entirely possible that the second
thread could read the view count while
the first thread is still doing its
calculation and yeah that's a really
simple calculation it's just adding one
but it still takes a few tics of a
processor so both of those right
processes would put the same number back
into the database and we've missed a
view on popular videos there will be
collisions like that all the time worst
case you've got ten or a hundred of
those requests all coming in at once and
one get stuck for a while for some
reason it'll still add just one to the
original number that it read and then
much later it will finally write its
result back into the database we've lost
any number of views in early databases
having updates that collided like that
could corrupt the entire system but
these days things will generate at least
keep working even if they're not quite
accurate and given that YouTube has to
work out not just views but and revenue
and money it has got to be accurate
anyway that's a basic race condition
when the code is trying to do two or
more things at once and the result
changes depending on the order that they
occur in an order that you cannot
control one solution is to put all the
requests in a queue and refuse to answer
any requests until the previous one is
completed now that's how single thread
and single computer programming works
how these old machines work until the
code finishes its task and says okay I
am ready for more now it just doesn't
accept anything else fine for simple
stuff does not scale up a million strong
hue to watch a YouTube video doesn't
sound like a great user experience but
that still happens somewhere for things
like
buying tickets to a show where it would
be an extremely bad idea to accidentally
sell the same seat to two people those
databases have to be 100% consistent so
from Big Show's ticket sites will
sometimes start a queue and limit the
number of people accessing the booking
site at once if you absolutely must
count everything accurately in real time
that's the best approach but for science
dealing with a big data like YouTube and
Twitter there is a different solution
called eventual consistency they have
lots of servers all over the world and
rather than reporting every view or
every retweet right away each individual
server will keep its own count bundle up
all the view counts and statistics that
it's dealing with and then it will just
update the central system when there's
time to do so updates don't have any
hours apart there could be minutes or
even just seconds but having a few
bundled updates that can be queued and
dealt with individually is a lot easier
on the central system and having
millions of requests all being shouted
at once actually for something on
YouTube scale that central database
won't just be one computer it'll be
settle and they'll all be keeping each
other up to date but that is a mess we
really don't want to get into right now
eventual consistency isn't right for
everything on YouTube if you are
updating something are like the privacy
settings of video it is important that
it is updated immediately everywhere but
compared to views likes and comments
that's a really rare thing to happen so
it's okay to stop everything but
everything else on hold
spend some time sorting out that
important change and come back later but
views and comments they can they can
wait for a little while just tell the
servers around the world to write them
down somewhere keeping log and then
every few seconds or minutes or maybe
even hours for some places those systems
can run through their logs do the
calculations and update the central
system once everyone has time all that
explains why view counts and subscriber
counts lag is sometimes why it can take
a while to get the numbers sorted out in
the end but it doesn't explain the
up-and-down numbers you saw at the start
in that tweet that's down to another
thing caching it's not just writing to
the database
that's bundled up reading is - if you
have thousands of people requesting the
same thing
it really doesn't make sense to have
them all hit the central system and have
it do the calculations every single time
so if Twitter again in 10,000 requests a
second for information on that one tweet
which is actually a pretty reasonable
amount for them it'll be ridiculous for
the central database to look up all the
details and do the numbers every time so
those requests are actually going to a
cache one of thousands or maybe tens of
thousands of caches sitting between the
end users and the central system each
cache looks up the details in the
central system once and then it keeps
the details in its memory for Twitter
each cache might only keep them for a
few seconds so it feels live but isn't
actually but it means that only a tiny
fraction of that huge amount of traffic
actually has to bother the central
database the rest comes straight out of
memory on a system that is built just
for serving those requests which is
orders of magnitude faster and if
there's a sudden spike in traffic
Twitter can just spin up some more cache
servers put them into the pool that's
answering everyone's requests and it all
just keeps working without any worry for
the database but each of those caches
will pull the information at a slightly
different time all out of sync with each
other when your request comes in its
routed to any of those available caches
and crucially it is not going to be the
same one every time they've all got
slightly different answers and each time
you're asking a different one eventual
consistency means that everything will
be sorted out at some point we won't
lose any data but it might take a while
before it's all in place sooner or later
the flood of retweets will stop or your
view count will settle down and once the
dust is settled everything can finally
get counted up but until then YouTube
and Twitter a little leeway counting
things accurately is really difficult
thank you very much the center for
computing history here in Cambridge
you've let me film with all this
wonderful old equipment and to all my
proofreading team who made your scripts
right
you